Habibe aus Afghanistan hat ein Geheimnis.
Ich kann weder meinen Namen
noch den meiner Familie schreiben.
Auch Paiman kann kaum lesen
und schreiben.
Ich bin zwei Jahre zur Schule gegangen,
dann habe ich als Friseurin gearbeitet
und dann war ich Hausfrau.
Habibe und Paiman gehören zu den Frauen,
für die es besonders schwer ist,
sich in Deutschland zu integrieren.
Paiman ist 23 Jahre und
Kurdin aus dem Irak.
Mit 14 wurde sie verheiratet.
Sie wohnt mit ihrem Mann
und drei schulpflichtigen Kindern
in einem Wohnheim in Köln.
Meistens bleibt die Familie
unter sich.
Ich habe keine deutschen Freundinnen.
Ich kenne nur einen Spanier.
Ich wünsche mir deutsche Freunde,
aber bisher hatte ich keine Chance.
Auch Habibe hat kaum Kontakt
zu deutschen Familien.
Nur eine deutsche Frau hat sie
im Wohnheim kennengelernt.
Wir sind seit einem Jahr
mit ihr befreundet.
Wenn wir Probleme haben
oder Briefe bekommen
von den Behörden, hilft sie uns.
Wir machen dann einen Termin,
meine Tochter trifft sich mit ihr
und bringt die Briefe mit.
Und wenn wir zum Arbeitsamt
gehen müssen,
dann begleitet sie uns.
Sie hilft uns sehr und wir sind
ihr sehr dankbar.
Dennoch fühlen sich die 44-jährige Witwe
Habibe und ihre Kinder nicht integriert.
Sie leben in einem ganz eigenen
kulturellen Umfeld,
jenseits der deutschen Gesellschaft.
Mit sogenannten niedrig-
schwelligen Alphabetisierungskursen
versucht die deutsche Politik,
an die vielen Frauen heranzukommen,
die hier gewissermaßen
unter dem Radar leben.
Das ist mein Buch.
Wir wollen den Frauen
überhaupt ermöglichen,
dass sie aus der Wohnung,
aus deren Häusern rausgehen,
auf die Straße gehen, dass sie
die Umgebung kennenlernen,
dass sie Deutsch lernen,
dass sie andere Frauen kennenlernen,
dass sie einfach Kontakt haben und sich
dann auch frei bewegen können.
Die Kurse werden vom Bundesamt
für Migration und Flüchtlinge angeboten.
Ein erster Schritt, der aber nicht
ausreiche, mahnen Experten.
Ich glaube, dass das so nicht reicht.
Man muss für eine gelingende Integration
vor allem die Kinder im Blick haben
und dafür ganz bestimmt auch die Mütter.
Sehr viele der Zuwanderer,
die jetzt zu uns kommen
und gekommen sind,
sind Muslime, die Väter sind sozusagen
im Sinne des altrömischen
„pater familias“ die,
die den Ton angeben und oft ihre
Frauen im Hintergrund halten.
Ja, wir versuchen ja gerade,
durch diese niederschwelligen
Frauenkurse die Frauen zu erreichen,
und es wäre sehr hilfreich, wenn
diese Denkstrukturen auch geändert werden,
aber machen wir uns nichts vor:
Das geht nicht von heute auf morgen.
Das dauert,
das (ist) ein langwieriger Prozess
und diese Kurse leisten
einen Beitrag dazu.
Wir hatten gestern Dialoge geübt.
Möchtest du auch kommen?
Super! Wo denn?
Seit 2015 sind mehr als eine Million
Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland gekommen.
Die Mittel für niedrigschwellige Angebote
wurden verdreifacht
auf mehr als 2 Millionen Euro im Jahr 2017.
Das reicht aber nur für eine erste
Orientierung im neuen Kulturkreis.
Doch viele Frauen kommen
darüber nie hinaus.
Auch bei Kostan Rida war das lange so.
Die Kurdin ist vor 17 Jahren nach
Deutschland gekommen,
zusammen mit ihrem Mann
und zwei Söhnen.
Ihr Mann war dagegen,
dass sie einen Integrationskurs besucht.
Irgendwann hat sie sich entschieden,
aus der Isolation auszubrechen.
Sie hat Deutsch gelernt und kümmert
sich nun selbst um Migrantinnen.
Sie beobachtet, dass viele überfordert
sind und gehemmt.
Viele Frauen möchten nicht, weil sie viel
beschäftigt mit den Kindern sind
oder sie haben keine Lust zum Lernen,
aber viele Frauen, die schon lange hier
sind, die können Deutsch verstehen
oder auch ein bisschen sprechen,
aber die wollen nicht sprechen.
Kostan hat es viel Mut gekostet, sich aktiv
in die neue Gesellschaft zu integrieren
und die Isolation hinter sich zu lassen.
Sie hat sich Hilfe gesucht bei der Caritas.
Doch damit mehr Frauen so handeln,
müsste auch die deutsche Politik
aktiver Gesicht zeigen
gegenüber den Herkunftskulturen,
sagen Experten.
Das wird zu Kollisionen führen mit den
familiären Vorgaben von Zuhause,
diese Kollisionen sollte der Staat
hier durchstehen,
auch Zumutungen an die Eltern und
sogar an die Kinder durchstehen
und das Ziel einer vernünftigen,
zivilgesellschaftlichen Integration
im Blick behalten.
Dafür könnten sie der Schlüssel sein.
Denn Paiman, Habibe und die anderen
Frauen wollen in Deutschland bleiben,
wollen, dass ihre Kinder hier aufwachsen.